hey I was just watching this episode of
scishow talk show and Derek from
veritasium is on it saying was that the
one about the chemical bonding energy
hey how did you you sent it to me didn't
you welcome to the science Asylum I am
Nick lucid in that episode of scishow
Derek says this that bonds are kind of a
signal not of energy being there but of
energy not being there and this things
are bound not the energy they have but
by the energy they have lost he's
technically right but I think he's
putting a little too much stock in the
numbers I'm guessing you have a better
way indeed I do
bonds are pretty small and kind of
abstract though so let's start with
something a little more familiar gravity
awkward Adam is down here on the ground
so she has zero potential energy myclone
is up here on this hill so he has
potential energy greater than zero
related to his height above the ground
there's nothing all that special about
the ground though if we call the ground
zero
then the potential energy of the subway
car is negative what does that even mean
I could just as easily have labeled the
subway at zero this makes both of them
positive but then my secret underground
lab is still negative it's like you're
saying the actual value of energy
doesn't matter that's exactly what I'm
saying usually what a physicist does to
settle this argument is choose zero
where nothing could ever be infinity
in other words zero potential energy is
at the ends of the universe which makes
all potential energies negative
including the moon's that's exactly what
Derek means when he says energy they
have lost but we're gonna be a little
more careful interpreting things
choosing infinity is just mathematically
convenient for astrophysics here on
earth
anyway here on earth other choices might
be more convenient the universe does not
care how we label it things only happen
when energy transforms so only the
differences really matter the cake is a
lie so what does this have to do with
atoms good question transition clone we
saw in the video on temperature that
chemical energy is just the potential
energy between atoms and molecules just
like the earth and the moon have
gravitational potential energy atoms or
more specifically their electrons have
electrical potential energy but did you
notice what I did there I said the atoms
or electrons have the energy not the
bonds you're so used to seeing molecules
like this with all these bars connecting
the atoms
yes that's duck tape it's cheap okay an
atomic bond is it any more tangible than
the bond that holds you on the earth or
the moon in orbit I mean it doesn't look
like this or anything wait wait doesn't
your body get energy from chemical bonds
no it gets it from chemicals not
chemical bonds if you've taken an intro
biology class you've probably heard of
cellular respiration you eat some food
and inhale some air these things
chemically react inside your body to
make breath some water and a bunch of
energy for you to use but that can be
extremely misleading energy only exists
to be possessed by particles and by
things made of those particles energy is
not standalone so this is incomplete
this energy isn't just floating around
in your body about 60 to 70% of it
becomes kinetic energy in the
surrounding molecules which we know is
body heat the other 30 to 40 percent
goes into a bunch of molecules called
ATP which is built from two other
molecules you have just floating around
so the actual process looks more like
this the energy your body uses is
possessed by ATP now let's bring it all
together the universe does not care how
you label things it doesn't do any math
it just works whether an energy is
negative or positive simply depends on
what you label zero in physics that's
usually the ends of the universe which
makes all potential energy negative
physicists like that because it makes
all bonds mathematically the same but
that's just a convenience in biology
you're not really concerned with the
overall meaning of a bond you just need
something that works you could label
zero at infinity or you could just look
at the chemical process you're dealing
with find the set of molecules with the
lowest energy
call that zero this will make the rest
of your Energy's positive and the
concept of negative energy is completely
avoided there's no universal truth in
either label choice
lastly the energy isn't in the bond a
bond is a completely abstract thing the
energy is in the atoms we only call it a
bond because under these circumstances
the atoms don't stray too far from each
other
when you go from a higher energy to a
lower energy the lost energy doesn't
disappear or start floating around on
its own it goes into other atoms
molecules or particles that's true
whether you're a molecule a person or a
planet so as one of your bonds ever
turned out to be negative energy let us
know in the comments several of mine
certainly have and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you